on a parfois proposé de passer à la
télévision à moi un d'autres gars de
chez nous en général les gens qui nous
proposait ne nous plaisait pas tellement
1975 cinq ans après la création de
charlie hebdo les journalistes de cet
hebdomadaire satirique se font toujours
rares à la télé mais les journalistes et
dessinateurs de l'hebdo savent bien
l'impact que peut avoir le petit écran
par exemple en 1977
reiser s'en sert pour faire une tribune
contre le nucléaire et jeudi que le
nucléaire c'est pas seulement eu un
dangereux comme ça c'est d'un danger
pour la société la société qui va se
stérilise et petit à petit et je moi je
dis on n'a jamais été aussi près du
bonheur avec le soleil et sur le compte
et les charlie hebdo à la télé c'est
avant tout des coups de gueule
mémorables fond j'avais ensuite toujours
foutu en décembre 1980 la publication du
journal doit cesser faute de lecteurs
quelques jours plus tard michel polac
invite l'équipe du journal as droit de
réponse injures grossièreté kavanagh
commence par s'emporter contre ses
propres lecteurs gens gueulent donc non
parce qu'ils dix minutes de jeu
manufrance qui n'est rien du tout ils
ont raison j'envoie mes jambes ce qui
est charlie hebdo et ils n'achètent pas
assez souvent
choron ivre insulter des lycéens
présents sur le plateau
ce sont des potes tisane qu'on nourrit
c'est très bien et qui ferment leur
gueule
merci chaud tandis qu en fin d'émission
signer explose contre ses contradicteurs
le journaliste dominique jamet et les
journalistes de l'hebdomadaire d'extrême
droite minute le droit de vous emmerde
et on en mairie
merde malgré ses coups de gueule des
anciens de charlie comme cabu et signer
vont continuer leur collaboration dans
l'émission au cours des années 80 en
charlie hebdo est relancé pour célébrer
leur retour dans les kiosques
c'est à la télévision que les
journalistes de charlie ont réservé une
petite surprise
l'équipe du journal satirique a décidé
de monter sa propre télé une télévision
de salut public comme ils disent
on en a marre d'avoir toujours les mêmes
quand le gouvernement provisoire créé
par l'équipe de charlie hebdo compte
s'installer sur le réseau de l'a5 la
candidature déposée en bonne et due
forme au csa n'aboutira pas
[Musique]